>> Sean: A NEW BOOK IS OUT.
IT'S CALLED "BATTLE FOR THE
SOUL."
BARACK OBAMA QUOTED SAYING
DONALD TRUMP IS A MAD MAN, A
RACIST, A SEXIST PIG AND A
CORRUPT MOTHER EFFER.
SO WE HAVE A SPECIAL MESSAGE FOR
BARACK.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT WE WOULD HAVE
A PRESIDENT THAT STARTED IN HIS
POLITICAL CAREER IN TWO
UNREPENDANT TERRORISTS.
ONE BOMBED THE NYPD POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND STATE DEPARTMENT
AND MORE.
ONE OF HIS PALS WAS QUOTED IN
911, 2001, SAYING HE WISH THEY
DID MORE.
I DON'T REGRET SETTING BOMBS.
OBAMA, THEY WERE YOUR FRIENDS.
THAT'S SICK.
I NEVER THOUGHT WE WOULD HAVE A
PRESIDENT THAT SAT IN THE PEWS
OF A RADICAL PASTOR FOR 20 PLUS
YEARS THAT THE SUNDAY AFTER 9-11
SAID NO, NO, NO, NOT GOD BLESS
AMERICA.
G.D. AMERICAN AND AMERICA'S
CHICKENS COMING HOME TO ROOST.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NO, NO, NOT GOD BLESS
AMERICA.
GOD DAMN AMERICA.
IT'S IN THE BIBLE.
>> BECAUSE OF THE STUFF WE'VE
DONE OVERSEAS IS BROUGHT BACK
INTO OUR OWN FRONT YARD.
AMERICA'S CHICKENS ARE COMING
HOME TO ROOST.
>> Sean: I NEVER THOUGHT WE
WOULD HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT
BROUGHT BLACK LIBERATION
THEOLOGY AND BOUGHT INTO THAT.
I NEVER THOUGHT WE WOULD ELECT A
PRESIDENT THAT HID FOR HIS
ENTIRE PRESIDENCY HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THAT RADICAL
RACIST ANTI-SEMITE LOUIS
FARRAKHAN.
THEY HID THAT PICTURE FOR NINE
YEARS.
WHAT A DISGRACE.
OR A PRESIDENT THAT RECOUNTED
REVEREND WRIGHT'S SERMON, WHITE
FOLKS NEEDS.
>> IT IS THIS WORLD WHERE CRUISE
SHIPS THROW AWAY MORE FOOD THAN
MORE SEE IN A YEAR.
>> Sean: I NEVER THOUGHT WE
WOULD ELECT SOL OLINSKI OR A
PRESIDENT BRAGGING ABOUT DOING
DRUGS AND SAID HE TRIED THEM
ENTHUSIASTI
ENTHUSIASTICALLY.
>> I SPENT THE LAST TWO YEARS OF
HIGH SCHOOL IN A DAZE.
I KEPT PLAYING BASKETBALL,
ATTENDED CLASSES SPARINGLY,
DRANK HEAVILY AND TRIED DRUGS.
IT DIDN'T MATTER IF YOU SMOKED
REEFER IN A DORM ROOM OR ON THE
BEACH WITH GUYS THAT LOOKED FOR
AN EXCUSE TO BRAWL.
>> YOU LIED.